on the streets of bagram
some optimism about life after the us
military departure
we should not worry about the us
withdrawal we are muslims and depend on
our god
we cannot rely on the u.s as there were
russians here in the past
now americans we should not wait for
another superpower to come
and help us and we should not worry
about them anymore
aziz amri's dream of self-reliance may
not be shared by many within the afghan
government
they're accusing the u.s of leaving the
bagram air base last week without
advanced notice
something the americans have been quick
to deny
i can tell you that afghan leaders
civilian and military
were appropriately coordinated with and
briefed about the turnover
of bagram air base in fact the u.s
central command said on tuesday
bagram was the seventh and final
military base
turned over to afghan control they said
the handover took
several weeks and that the u.s isn't
abandoning afghanistan
we have every intention of continuing an
ongoing president present
in kabul which is continuing even after
we bring
our military who are serving
a home by the end of august but other
images from the provinces
tell a different story afghan soldiers
have either deserted their posts
and fled or as taliban media puts it
decided to join the opposition but the
afghan government says
this is a temporary setback this
situation will not continue
and the taliban are not able to
protect the orioles or the districts
which have
been taken over by them and we are
getting ready and we will
launch offensive operations soon and we
will capture the arias
if the biden administration is worried
about these developments
and the taliban's commitment to a
peaceful future it's not saying so
analysts say there is reason to be
concerned
you know it's in the interest of the
united states uh it's in the interest of
countries in the region to ensure that
the afghan government does not collapse
but we're heading to a pretty dark place
at the moment some on the streets of
bagram already think the dark place has
arrived
you can see now a lot of districts have
surrendered to the taliban even some
afghan forces have fled to tajikistan
and i'm telling you that afghan forces
will not be able to secure our country
if there will be no foreign support we
will witness once again
civil war here a pivotal or
perhaps inevitable moment for the afghan
people
after 20 years of the u.s led war
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington